it's impossible to know but this is
probably Henry Ford's head and this this
is definitely Henry Ford washing up by a
stream starting in 1915 these four men
camped and road trip together regularly
let me show you you've got John
Burroughs imagine somebody is famous as
Neil deGrasse Tyson or Bill Nye but for
nature there's tire magnate Harvey
Firestone Henry Ford founder afford
Motor Company and Thomas Edison
America's most famous inventor this
group's adventures took two American
classics and brought them to a whole new
level the road trip and the publicity
stunt too
[Music]
you could get lost in John Burroughs
beer brews is the least likely of this
road trip group but he's kind of the
linchpin he was conservation elite
here's his beard and Teddy Roosevelt at
Yellowstone in 1903 he knew the
environmental implications of industry
when the Model T came out in 1908 he
called it a demon on wheels so Henry
Ford sent him one and it became friends
this is John Burroughs inside his demon
on wheels forded law known Edison as his
mentor and Firestone was a natural
fourth from the tire connection the
group started road tripping together and
they called themselves the vagabonds
[Music]
high jinks ensued yep Henry Ford just
climbed a tree after driving over
primitive roads they communed with
nature following a typical routine
Burroughs went for long walks Firestone
red Edison down and Henry Ford well he
chopped wood he really hated wood
along their routes they met other
inventors and business Titans who
occasionally tagged along according to
one essay by a fellow road trip er
Thomas Edison also called Firestone and
his son Harvey jr. dudes for an entire
trip now the meaning at the time is a
little bit different because dude might
have been a city person or a well
dressed person let's not lose sight of
the fact that Thomas Edison was walking
around calling Harvey Firestone dude
when he wanted to get his attention they
took a lot of trips this 1918 route was
typical of their regular journeys and
the group of great men earned headlines
everywhere they went on this trip they
traveled throughout Virginia hit North
Carolina and zipped back up to Maryland
their fun road trips were a phenomenon
like here when Asheville North Carolina
papers covered their arrival visit and
departure it was called a trip with
friends but it wasn't just a normal road
trip here's a secret when the most
powerful men in the country go on a road
trip they do it a little differently
than everybody else honestly this was
glamping they brought along a film crew
with big bulky cameras they had chefs
and five-star service the entire time
this table it spins
besides delicious meals cooked in the
open air these trips served a purpose
newspapers reported on the vagabonds as
if they actually were vagabonds they
said that the trip showed a fellowship
with the common man and a governing
concern for the little man's interests
and welfare at the same time they were
wrangling camera crews to film how
normal they were they were also managing
their business interests that early 1916
trip included a meet up with Edward and
Hurley a businessman and the chair of
the United States shipping board an
emergency naval agency established as
the United States came closer to
entering World War
in Pennsylvania the power players
conferred as one observer described it
to divide up the work ahead in
manufacturing World War one breaks out
roadtrip totally came on future trips
with the vagabonds as well ford also
gobbled up land to explore steam power
and agricultural possibilities in the
group met with agriculturalists and
botanists in 1918 while on the road ford
had been drafted into a Senate campaign
as well which he narrowly lost we'll
never know everything they talked about
according to burrows ford shared his
anti-semitic conspiracy theories over
late-night chats the vagabonds were
camping but they were also making deals
and running a PR campaign highlighting
each of the men's professional interests
and making them seem fun and accessible
this is Henry Ford's toast and that's
the thing they served up to the public
John burrows died in 1921 he was 83
after his death when the troops
continued that new guy chopping wood its
president warren g harding still even by
the standards of the vagabonds the
publicity and entourage grew too big the
road trips stopped in 1924 but the
vagabonds had a lasting impact on the
american notion of the road trip and how
powerful people network even when
they're taking naps so was it a
publicity stunt or a real road trip with
buddies maybe it was both or maybe it
was some third thing all together this
is a nearly hundred-year-old campfire
John Burroughs wrote an essay about the
trip and why he thought they took it
maybe it was even true we grow weary of
our luxuries and conveniences we react
against our complex civilization and
longed to get back for a time to first
principles we cheerfully endure wet cold
smoke mosquitos black flies and
sleepless nights just to touch naked
reality once more
oh it's up that was the first episode of
Almanac roadtrip Edition and now we're
gonna be reading some comments and we're
gonna reveal the name of this guy which
you all helped choose in the comments to
the trailer so yeah reading comments on
the internet it's not a new thing but
I'm particularly inspired by potato jet
he is a camera and tech blogger and he's
just generally hilarious and really
smart so please go check him out he
always does this
at the end of his videos and I love it
so we're gonna try it here I gave
everybody the challenge of naming this
wavy floaty guy top comment by far
Chris Saunders says he has a name it's
wacky waving inflatable arm-flailing
tube-man if you don't know this is a
family guy reference why key waving
inflatable arm-flailing through ma'am
very funny but i asked you all to name
him not the writers for a family guy and
you know i just would have called Seth
MacFarlane if we needed that so the
second most popular comment is actually
about route 66
it's from Sebastian electron and he says
that's what the world-famous route 66
looks like I thought it was more
glamorous in that trailer I'm actually
sitting on route 66 the whole time so if
you notice me like looking up a lot it's
because I'm worried I'm gonna be run
over by a car so there are really
desolate sections like that and then
there are also unpaved sections which I
also show in that trailer and you'll
learn the whole history and everything
about route 66 in Episode four of this
road trip edition the name of your
friend lab flute of knowledge 20 what
that means but thumbs up to that he and
Gracie Agel his name should be all
maniac he seems like a wild one alright
without further ado let's scroll up to
the winner so is pretty much the second
most popular answer it's from Zin versus
its Mac runs with Almanac lots of Mac
trucks on the road it makes sense it's
fun and it's easy to fit on screen so
gävle Mac that's it there's a desk down
here by the way
but gavel was my fist and it hurts
alright so that's it in the next episode
I will be answering any questions or
concerns that you have about the
vagabonds from this video so drop those
below let me know and until then happy
glamping yep said the word glamping
again